Yeah. How are we doing it? Um, I can
share screen or I can switch to stream
view. Probably share screen's easier.
And do me a favor. Something isn't
working. I'm going to take the
headphones off for the talk. So, just
message me uh on that Discord channel.
Yeah.
All right.
Yeah, sure.
you say something to me just to test the
audio.
>> Mic.
>> Uh, yeah. Hold on. Let me switch.
Hopefully,
>> it's choosing the right one. Yep.
like it.
>> You say something once more for me.
>> Test.
>> Yeah, perfect.
>> Okay, I'll I'll do a quick introduction
and then hand over to you in a second.
>> Sure.
>> Hello everyone. Welcome to our our last
talk of the day. I'm very pleased to
introduce you to Dr. Dr. Joseph Suarez.
Uh he is the founder of Puffer AI and um
they work a lot on reinforcement
learning research. Um and if you
remember our talk from earlier about
drones, that's kind of the workforce
behind uh what we were doing and many of
the kind of core reinforcement learning
projects really at the the forefront of
of research. Um Joseph is going to talk
to you about um neural MMO which he did
during his PhD at MIT and also puff as a
reinforcement learning library in
general. So I'll hand it over to Joseph
now. Thank you.
>> Thanks for the introduction Sam.
Let me share my screen here.
This coming through well.
uh do this.
>> Yep, we're all good.
>> Cool. I will uh pop these off. You can
let me know if anything's wrong in the
uh the Discord messages.
>> Yep, sounds good.
>> Okay, perfect. Thanks for the
introduction. Hello everyone. I'm going
to be talking to you about Whoops, this
is the wrong slide.
Let's not give that talk by mistake.
It's a much shorter talk.
>> Title of the talk today is reinforcement
learning 10,000 times faster. Uh I'm
going to be talking to you about my work
on neural MMO from my PhD as well as
what I've been doing in the last couple
of years on making reinforcement
learning super fast, super stable,
broadly accessible, some algorithm work
as well. And uh it's also just going to
be the story of a very long project that
started as something very very far out
there um like way way way off the beaten
path and then eventually came back
around to being something that is now
broadly useful. uh really helping people
get into the field and also being
deployed uh for companies as well.
So brief primer, we're not going to get
too technical. It's mostly about the
journey and about the tech here. Not
going to get too too deep into the
details of the RL, but uh for those
unfamiliar, it is a sub area of AI that
deals with training agents through
interaction, learning through
experience. So you have something called
an environment which is a game, a
simulator, a robot, anything that can be
interacted with. And then you have an
agent which is the thing doing the
interacting. And the agent is usually
parameterized by a neural network. So
you have a neural network playing a
game, controlling a robot, uh taking
actions, making decisions in industrial
sim. It's very very broad. Uh now before
we really get started here, just
something for fun.
What does it mean to make something 500
times faster? So, this is a puffer fish.
Uh, if a puffer fish is really, really
try and it can swim at 1 to 2 meters per
second. What does it mean to make
something 500 times faster? Like, what's
about 500 times faster than this?
A fighter jet.
So, making something from as fast as a
buffer to as fast as a fighter jet,
that's a pretty darn good improvement,
right? What about 10,000 times?
you know, an object that's about 10,000
times faster than a puffer fish. I was
thinking, oh, probably a rocket, but
yeah, those are kind of slow. So, um,
here's four of them. So, the point of
this is this is just an absolutely
ridiculous speed improvement, right?
Like, you should never be able to make
anything 10,000 times faster because if
you can, that means that something was
10,000 times too slow to begin with. And
really, you should only have to sneeze
at something that is 10,000 times too
slow to at least make it a little bit
better. But lo and behold, this was
actually the case in reinforcement
learning that it was such a
scientifically dominated field that had
so little emphasis on the engineering
that things were legitimately 10,000
times slower than they could be. Uh, and
this made it very difficult to actually
iterate quickly on RL research. I think
it's one of the major reasons you don't
see as much of it as you should see
today and it is now coming back and
you're seeing a lot more people doing
stuff because it's way way easier to
iterate quickly and that has contributed
to a bunch of algorithmic advancements
and we're going to talk about all of
that. But first just one quick little
result demo here. Um this is from my RLC
talk uh last year and this is training
breakout. So this is just a little GIF
recorded from my local desktop where we
trained an agent to play Breakout in
24ish seconds. So before puffer lib to
train an agent on breakout you had
libraries that would take hours or even
days in order to get even a reasonable
policy. And here you can just train this
locally, super quick. You know, you have
an idea, you can try it out, you can try
another idea. Very, very fast iteration
cycle. Really, really great for
research. And then if we watch this
thing play the game, I've managed to
stall you long enough for the whole
training to complete. And there you go.
And you can watch this thing solve the
entire game. It's several million steps
per second training, which is already
around a thousand times faster than what
was out there before. I'll show you at
the very end of this how we get from
there to the latest, where now we can
solve this in just a few seconds. And
I'll actually demo that live for you if
we have time. Uh, but this is a nice
little starting point. But of course,
the point of reinforcement learning is
not just to solve breakout. It's to
solve a wide variety of problems, right?
We just like these games because they're
quick, they're interpretable, and they
let us get a lot of the infrastructure
right. And a lot of my work has dealt
with how do we make reinforcement
learning useful in large complex
environments where we can ask hard
questions and uh study what is needed
for this sub area of AI to advance.
Now this project started a long time ago
probably around 2017. I was thinking
about it even a little bit before that
and the really the relevant questions
back then were what is the right
environment for studying intelligence
for making contributions creating better
algorithms and then how do we build it?
It was pretty obvious even back then
that you wanted something that should be
computationally efficient and
interpretable. So you need a simulator
that can run quickly and that you can
tell what is going on.
You also want something realistic, but
going too far down the path of realism
is actually a bit of a trap because it's
hard to make something that is fast and
realistic. So, what you end up wanting
is actually cognitive realism. You want
something that behaves in roughly the
same manner as the real world at an
intellectual level that poses the same
types of challenges in exploration and
credit assignment. And if you were to
sort of break down the things that make
problems hard, you want a lot of those
same challenges to be present in
whatever environment you build.
So when I was first starting this work,
I started building some stuff. It was
2017 and you know within the next couple
of years around there, that's when the
big labs were starting to scale up
reinforcement learning. You had open AI
with Dota. You had um Deep Mind with
Alph Go and solving Starcraft, Alpha
Star. You also had these somewhat
lesserk known but still pretty out there
projects, emerging tool use and capture
the flag. And really the idea was we're
just going to scale up reinforcement
learning. We're going to see what's
possible. we're going to solve some
really hard games and we're going to see
where that goes. And they got some
tremendously impressive results, some of
which still have not been surpassed to
this day. Uh, but for my own work, most
of these environments are not open
source. And even if they were, they're
very slow. Like you need a thousand GPUs
to even do anything. You're not going to
be able to quickly tweak things and see,
oh, what if the agent has to do this?
What if it has to use that? So this was
just like far too large for the types of
stuff that I was interested in. So I
decided to make my own environment. And
I landed on the idea of using massively
multiplayer online games as the basis
for inspiration.
And the reason for this, if you're not
familiar with the genre, is that this is
just a perfect storm for um you end up
with this genre of games that was
optimized to run cities of players on
'90s hardware. So way more
computationally efficient than other
genres and at the same time they were
still interesting for people to play.
It's not like they were trivial, right?
You'd end up with emergent economies,
forces of supply and demand,
specialization to different skills, both
in terms of the players being good at
different things and also them
optimizing their characters to be geared
out for specific things. And then you
get cooperation and competition among
players. Really a very sophisticated
sort of world set. Um, I actually credit
most of my ideas in reinforcement
learning directly to a deep
understanding of how a lot of these
games were built back in the 90s and the
types of tricks that were used to
introduce interesting gameplay on a
tight computational budget.
So, I decided to build my own
environment that was largely inspired by
MMOs. There were some other things
floating around at the time. Artificial
life was very big back then. So, how do
we take inspiration from survival and
from like natural ecology and um you
know these sorts of things? So, it was
kind of a mix at first, but that was the
idea. Let's just put as much interesting
stuff as possible into one fast
environment that you can run at home,
have a bunch of agents, a lot of
different types of interactions, and see
what types of things we can study in
that setting and not need a thousand
GPUs to run it.
So, the first part of this is really
going to be about the process of
building this. And this is something
that I spent years and years on. And I
sort of want to share with you a little
bit of what went on behind the scenes
there. Because in these very long form
projects, when you're doing something
that's very, very far out left field,
the right questions to ask are not
obvious. And often times you go down
lots of rabbit holes answering the wrong
questions or answering the right
questions in the wrong way. And I want
to share a little bit of what that looks
like and how difficult this process is.
But then ultimately this all comes back
to make it possible to do what I did
today with Puffer where now this stuff
just works. It works broadly and I know
for a fact that it's going to continue
to work as we scale it up to more
complex environments because I built one
of the most complex ones out there.
This is the earliest screenshot I could
find. Uh the first sort of commit I made
in 2017. I really didn't know what I was
doing back then at all. I decided to do
it anyways. I sort of had this core idea
that okay, MMOs are interesting, AI is
interesting. I wasn't even doing proper
RL back then, but I did it anyways and I
wanted to share some of these early
screenshots.
So, this was the first prototype I made.
Uh, you can see it's just awful knockoff
Minecraft. And this was completely the
wrong environment. It turns out
Minecraft is a very bad environment for
this type of RL work. I tried to get
some agents running around chopping down
trees. It was super slow. it was way too
complicated for what I needed and it
didn't have the complexities in the
right areas that you didn't need. So I
went back to square one and I ended up
with something sort of like this.
So in this environment, it's a much
simpler setting, but we got agents that
need food, they need water, so they need
these two resources to survive. And they
were able to learn these sort of
cyclical foraging patterns where they
would go back and forth between food and
water. This wasn't even RL at first. It
was just very simple genetic algorithms,
but it was something. We could put a lot
of agents into an environment. We had a
way that we could see what was going on.
We could start introducing more
mechanics. We could load in different
maps. This was the start of it. So, I
continued building this out a little
bit. You can see on the left I was
playing around with, well, what if
there's a market that they can buy and
sell things? What if they're like
enemies, chickens and goblins and
things? You can sort of see the little
pixelated characters that they can
fight. just introducing some additional
complexities to see what would happen.
It was very exploratory at first and
what if we have other maps that they can
use to sort of introduce different types
of exploration challenges in what do
they learn then? So around this time uh
OpenAI was doing their Dota 1 v1s and I
ended up going there for about six
months as an intern to really work on
making this full first version of neural
MMO. They were thinking a lot about
different RL environments and it was
just the perfect place to build this
type of stuff. So this is one of the
very early renders that I believe I
built while I was there. And you can see
we have now an isometric render. There's
also a top down toggle. You can see
there's a little bit more of the stacks
from before expanded. And on the right
there's actually this little command
console where you could type in
different things or hit different keys
and you would get different
visualizations
uh overlaid on top of the environment
that you'll see later. And this was kind
of co-designing a visualization toolkit
with an environment. So we could
simultaneously iterate on building an
interesting environment and visualizing
what on earth these agents are actually
learning.
This was the first public version that I
released. This was neural 1.0. You'll
see that the graphics will swap around a
whole bunch throughout uh the course of
this. It's not just to make it look
fancier. It's also because it's really
tough to know what's going on a lot of
the time. You know, these are not people
playing a game doing what you'd expect
people to be doing. Agents discover all
sorts of weird stuff and it's not always
clear if the agent is doing something
correct or if there's something wrong
with the environment, right? So, you
need a lot of ability to visualize stuff
and that was sort of a major finding
early on is when you start scaling up
environment complexity, you actually
need a way better interpretability
toolkit.
Um, so the initial environment it had
food and water forging from before and
also agents could fight each other with
a few different combat styles. This was
very simple, but it was actually much
more complex than most of what was out
there in multi-agent reinforcement
learning and particularly for
multi-agent RL that you could actually
run on one computer.
This was the initial graphic. This is
what it looked like with the agents
running around. These are some trained
agents. They could learn to explore the
map. They could learn to forge for
resources. They would fight each other.
Pretty basic, but already kind of fun to
watch.
We also had a lot of work on these
static maps early on. This is one of the
things where it really wasn't clear what
was the correct like setup for these.
So, one of the initial ideas was, well,
what if we make a lot of different maps
that pose different exploration
challenges? So, in this one, the idea
was that there is water, there is food,
and the agents have to ping pong back
and forth between food and water as they
explore the map. And we did actually get
this to work where the agents would all
start off in the north of the map, and
they would get pretty much all the way
to the bottom. They wouldn't cover the
entire thing. Uh, but what we realized
was ultimately it was pretty hard to
train agents on just one map. There
really just isn't that much signal. You
kind of need them to see more different
things during training. So we ended up
realizing that you needed to randomize
the maps at least a bit during training.
And that's what we did for the first
release. Uh we shipped randomly
generated maps, a nice little training
setup so that you could create some
agents and some visualization tools for
researchers to use to just explore this
stuff generally.
After that I finished up my undergrad. I
started my PhD and I started working on
this more seriously. And uh at that
time, right, it was mostly like, let's
just get this pop tool, get polished up.
Um we can sort of see that it's working,
but stuff is still pretty fiddly. It's
still pretty hard to use. You can't
always tell exactly what's going on. So,
we started just iterating on the
platform itself quite a bit. And one of
the first things I remember adding in
was some sort of persistent progression
where agents could level up their
ability to gather food and gather water.
They could level up their combat skills.
And this would make it so that agents
would be stronger later on. So it wasn't
so homogeneous, right? It wasn't just
always the same types of behaviors.
There's actually a little bit of
decision-making that had to go into it
based on what other agents were around,
how strong you were, how they were, and
the like.
Now, this is one spot that I want to
pause on, not to explain this figure
because this is just a really fancy
neural net architecture, but to kind of
explain why I had figures like this at
all. And this goes back to the idea of
when you're doing something very far out
in left field, it's not even clear what
the right questions are that you should
be asking. And back then, one of the
questions was, well, how on earth do we
design neural networks for these things?
Because we have a big blob of game data
on the input side, and then there's a
big blob of action data on the output
side, and these don't fit nicely with
your standard neural net architectures
at all. It's very structured data, and
we have to come up with networks to
figure out how to handle that. and they
would get very very large and very
fiddly. If you want a really crazy
example of that, check uh go look up the
uh the OpenA5 Dota architecture. It's
nuts. So, I came up with something that
I thought was at least pretty decent
that let you specify all of the objects
in the environment that you could
observe and they could all have a bunch
of different properties and it would
give you a way to sort of crunch them
all down into something that you could
put into a neural network. But this was
ultimately a ton of work. it was super
slow and this was such a pain that
nowadays I actually just designed the
environments a little bit differently
where they can do the same thing
internally but the data that they send
to the agent just doesn't look like this
because I know what a pain it is to deal
with. So that's kind of like one of
those things that early on you really
don't know whether you need to solve
this problem or if there's a way around
it. Ultimately we found a way around it
but this workound at least was enough to
power a couple years worth of research.
Neural kept advancing. It kept getting
more complex. You'll see a quick demo of
behaviors in here, I believe. Yeah. So,
this is the policies that we were
training maybe a couple years into my
PhD. We had agents that would explore
the maps. The maps got a little bit
larger and more complex. The agents
could level up. Now, that made it a lot
harder because they had to think about,
okay, am I strong? Am I weak? Um, there
was a lot of complexity introduced by
that. And it was pretty stable. And the
thing I was really happy about is that
you actually had a good idea of what
agents were learning and what they were
doing, which was quite rare at the time.
So you could see exactly where all the
agents have been splatted right directly
into this renderer.
And then you could also see uh you could
reach into the agents and see whether
they thought that their position was
good or bad. And you could even smooth
it over the entire map and see, ah,
okay, they've learned correctly that
they should be near food and near water.
And you could go watch the agents. You
could say, "Okay, they're fighting.
going to go get some food, going to go
get some water. Cool. That looks
reasonable. And for comparison, the
untrained policies, it's very, very
obvious they've learned something
reasonable. This is what happens if you
just behave randomly.
So, we continued building this thing out
as a benchmark. We kept writing papers
on, okay, this is the latest version.
These are the features. These are the
some of the things that we've seen the
agents doing. These are some of the new
questions that we're thinking about with
the latest version, with the new stuff
that's in the environment. We started
introducing like an achievement system
where they could make progress along
different axes. Um, we started trying to
like figure out if we could put multiple
policies into the same environment. Lots
of things like this.
We also made it a lot larger. So the
maps could be up to a,000 by a,000 which
would take them 10 minutes to walk
across. Much more persistent
progression.
And even the smaller maps that we would
use for experiments, we made a little
bit larger. So we could really see,
okay, know they're learning to cover an
entire reasonable map. On the big maps,
they would cover a good chunk of it.
Once all this was pretty stable, we
started looking for ways to make the
environment more complex and interesting
because that really doesn't look too
much like an MMO yet, right? There's not
really the like the different skills,
um, the different progressions, the
different specializations. So, this was
what we wanted to introduce next.
And the idea was just to add in an
equipment system, an inventory system, a
bunch of new professions, a bunch of new
resources to gather where agents could
run around the map. They could level up
like a mining skill, a fishing skill, a
few other skills, and they could get
higher and higher quality resources by
doing that. And then they could sell and
buy resources with each other on a
global market. So they could make their
own little economy. There were weapons,
there were different ammunitions, all
sorts of different things that all sort
of fed into each other. And you know,
you always needed something that
somebody else had and you always had
something that somebody else wanted.
So we had this question of, well, is it
actually good to specialize, right? Is
there a reason to make use of a specific
one of these or are all the agents just
going to always be wanting to do the
same thing? And we found that actually
very quickly when you introduce any sort
of system like this, specialization is a
pretty natural thing that just becomes
incentivized. Um, even with some very
simple scripted agents, we found that
going around and just gathering all the
resources nearby is a worse strategy
than seeking out a specific type of
resource, leveling up the skill
associated with it, and then being able
to sell very high quality items from
that specific skill. So, it's better to
be able to have a specialty, sell stuff
in your specialty, and just buy
everything that you need from other
specialists. And this ends up better for
everybody. Like all the agents in the
simulation when you do this end up with
better equipment, better tools, better
stuff overall. So I was very happy with
this result. It kind of showed that the
simulation at least in principle when
you build stuff like this, you do
incentivize some things that we care
about seeing uh in the real world,
right? Specialization and
diversification of skills and so on. So
this made it into neural 2.0, 0 which
was the last major version that we
published during my PhD as a data set
and benchmark.
This was the environment. We did a whole
bunch of work on the back end of this as
well. Um there was this fancy
architecture that allowed us to keep the
whole thing in Python. So really
hackable for researchers, but at the
same time it had this vector database in
the back end that you really didn't even
have to care about. you could just write
normal code and it was still able to run
several thousand steps per second which
was very fast at the time at the very
least. We also got the training to be
much much faster than what else was out
there at the time and we got it in a
very very simple library uh which was
quite difficult to do with an
environment that has these properties.
You know typically environments like
this had these bespoke gigantic training
code bases. So we got it down to just a
few hundred lines of training code. uh
with clean RL we actually were using the
very very first version of puffer lib
for this like when it was just in its
infancy and this was kind of the first
time that it all came together into
something that seemed like a real useful
awesome problem to study. I spent a
bunch of my PhD running competitions on
that version and then the versions
leading up to that. So we'd go to
conferences uh leading up to conferences
we would challenge people to train
agents on neural MMO. These ended up
being very popular. So we ran one at
Ichkai, we ran one at Nuruk the next
year that ended up being I believe the
largest competition in RL that year and
then we had an additional one in 2023 on
2.0.
And the idea was that you would train an
agent or train a team of agents. We'd
take everybody's agents, we'd stick them
all into the same environment and we'd
see how they do against each other on
various different tasks.
And it was pretty cool because quite
quickly we would see different
participants agents learning different
strategies um just by virtue of
differences in the approach the authors
had taken not necessarily attempting to
incentivize one specific strategy. There
was just a lot of diversity in the
environment itself as to what approaches
were viable. So we would see some agents
that would like explore around the outer
section of the map. We'd see some agents
in teams that would play split. Some
would play very close together. Some
would like break off into two sub teams.
quite a lot of strategic diversity.
In one of the later competitions, we
decided we decided that it should be
more like a battle royale type thing
where it was the last one standing wins
because this gave you a very very clear
objective. And we ended up seeing some
of the strategies emerge that we see
players using, human players using in
actual battle royale games. So, in that
genre, there's almost always something
that pushes you towards the center by
inflicting damage on you over time. And
one things that you'll see players do is
if they can, if the game allows for it,
they'll just kind of stand there for a
while and tank the damage so that they
let everybody else fight and then they
can kind of come in at the end and just
take out the last couple people that are
pretty weak. And the agents learn to do
that. Lo and behold, and they learn to
do a bunch of other things that we see
in that genre as well. So that was super
cool to see.
Early on in competitions, a lot of
people were submitting scripted agents
that were pretty good and competitive.
But by the end of it, we actually had
all the reinforcement learning
approaches just being way, way better.
So this was also in line with what we
expected. Takes a little bit of time to
get RL up in one running, but when you
do, you can't compete with it.
So from my PhD overall, I expected to go
in having to come up with a bunch of new
fancy algorithms in order to study the
types of things that we wanted. But it
turns out that the base algorithm that
we were using and most people were using
of PO was just very very effective even
at small scale. And the main barrier was
just not being able to study the right
problems, not having interpretability,
not knowing how to build efficient
simulations, like a completely different
set of problems from what most people
were looking at ended up being the major
bottleneck. And neural MMO ended up
being both a very good environment for
figuring this out as well as a playbook
for building simulations in the future.
which then brings me to what I spent my
time doing in the last couple years
after my PhD.
So, we had all this working. Um, but it
wasn't everywhere yet, right? We kind of
knew what to do, but we didn't know how
to quickly make RL work in a variety of
settings yet. We kind of had the
playbook, but we didn't have all the
infrastructure and stuff set up. So the
very first thing I did after graduating
was to uh create these really simple
wrappers using what I'd learned from
neural MMO that would let you take
neural MMO or net hack or basically any
other environment and just run it with
the simplest tools out there. So the
idea is that instead of studying simple
problems because you're constrained by
infrastructure, you can study quite
complex problems. And the idea with
puffer lip was okay this will push RL
towards more interesting problems and
we'll see where we can go from there
once we are able to get RL onto more
interesting problems. Now the next thing
is once you had this and once everything
became a lot simpler the speed issue
became very very clear and the first
thing that I noticed was that actually a
lot of the slowness of RL wasn't even
coming from training it was coming from
the environments and specifically you
always run a bunch of copies of your
environment on different processes and
the multipprocessing backend that was
used for this everywhere was just
abysmally slow like often times just as
slow as running it on one core. for
especially for these more complex
environments because they weren't built
for that. So I wrote a new
multipprocessing backend from the ground
up using what I learned from puffer uh
not from puffer from neural mo with this
compatibility wrapper in mind what would
work for everything. We eliminated a lot
of redundancy a lot of overhead and
immediately we got stuff like 10 times
faster on a whole bunch of environments
and even we got a reasonable speed
bottleneck even on some of the standard
environments where it should have been
fast to begin with. So this was kind of
an eye openener because you're not
supposed to be able to make stuff way
way faster just easily. Like it's
supposed to be that stuff is pretty well
optimized and if stuff isn't then that's
like okay well what else is slow out
there right? How much more can we do
just by making some stuff faster. So we
realized that even after we did this the
bottleneck still wasn't training it was
still the environment simulation. So
okay let's write some environments in C.
Let's see how that goes. Now, it didn't
really start off in C. First, it was S
Python and then stuff got ported over to
something else. But then eventually, we
ended up in C. And I started streaming a
lot of my development as well because I
thought it would be fun. And uh as a
result of this, I was kind of sitting
there jamming on environments in C for
research. And a bunch of people thought,
"Oh, that looks like a fun project.
Let's build some environments as well
and contribute them." So this ended up
being a big open source project in which
we have tons and tons of people building
these environments and they're directly
useful to research because now we have a
huge library of super super fast
simulations and we can just test our
reinforcement learning on all of them
and in fact because they're in C you can
compile them to web assembly they go
right on the website in puffer.ai super
easy and fast.
So this just made everything way way
faster. And there were additional
optimizations I'm skipping over a little
bit here, but I made a version of neural
MMO as a followup to my PhD um in C and
using the new vectorzation, using the
new stuff in Puffer Lib, and it got to
like several hundred thousand steps per
second training per GPU. Uh, and this
meant that we could train on a thousand
times more data than I could ever hope
to have trained on during my PhD. So we
were able to train a model on 12,000
years worth of gameplay. That's 200 uh
640 billion observations. So more than a
pabyte. If you're thinking about
language models these days is using a
lot of data training on tens of
trillions of tokens. So like you know
tens to maybe hundred terabytes of data.
Like look how much data we're using on
one machine. It was just huge.
And as a result, we were able to train
agents with this nice log linear
learning curve that actually were better
than me at the game and I wrote the
game. And they came up with some stuff
in the game that I didn't expect to be
possible when they programmed it in. And
this is pretty much like the full neural
MMO 2 as well. Pro arguably even more
complex. There's skills that you can
level up, different professions, their
different items, equipment, there's a
market, they can buy and sell stuff. And
they figured out a lot of this stuff
very, very well. and especially they
figured out a lot of very mechanically
difficult stuff to do with the combat as
well.
Now when you make stuff really fast um
experimentation itself becomes a lot
easier because you can simply run more
experiments and one of the things that
became very obvious is that the
hyperparameters were a major major
bottleneck in RL. You essentially have
all these knobs you have to fiddle with.
Um it's similar to other areas of AI.
It's way way way harder and worse in RL
I would say because you have a ton of
different problems you're optimizing for
not just one. And this was the next
thing that we did is we made a really
good hyperparameter sweep algorithm. We
tested across everything. Lo and behold,
this made it way easier to do research
because now you actually have this whole
problem of oh are my hyperparameters bad
just goes out the window. we were able
to make some core improvements to the
learning algorithm as well that weren't
like the crazy out there fancy new
algorithm variety, right? It wasn't the
type of thing that's going to be the
genius new thing that you publish, but
in practice when you evaluate them over
all the environments, there's some
really really good stability
improvements and they made us do a lot
better on a lot of the environments. So
we have articles on both of those and as
a result of this just with speed and
some small enhancements uh it's already
at the point now where you can kind of
just write up an environment run RL on
it if it doesn't work run a sweep on it
and you have it already working pretty
much out of the box on small
environments and if it doesn't work it's
probably because the environment is
wrong not the RL like you have a bug in
there somewhere you know go play it a
couple times see if it's messed up. Um,
now I don't have slides for the stuff
I'm doing now, but I'm going to spend a
couple minutes talking about it before I
take as many questions as you all have.
What I've been doing for the last 6 to 8
months is really going even deeper down
that rabbit hole. Okay, we made RL a
thousand times faster or 2,000 times
faster, whatever it was. Uh, how much
more can we go? Like what is the limit
of the hardware? And it turns out we
weren't even close to the limit of the
hardware then at all. Uh it really was
the case that from all the way from the
environment down to the vectorzation the
training implementations even into torch
itself that we were using. Same problem
with jacks by the way that doesn't fix
it either. Uh everything was poorly
designed for this. So what we started
doing is first of all I ported the
Python training code into the torch C++
API and I started writing some custom
kernels. And at first it was just like,
okay, these operations are kind of
inefficient. Let's see if we can fuse
some stuff. And we realized that torch
just has tons of little operations all
over the place. It's death by a thousand
cuts. So we started just fusing
operations together. Uh we had more and
more of the code in our custom kernels,
not within torch. And the speed of
training kept going up and up and up,
right? It started at two or three
million and then it was very quickly at
four or five, then it got to seven. We
got some new contributors interested in
the open- source side, helped on the
multipprocosting back end that helped on
some kernel optimizations. It got to
nine, it got to 11. We got mixed
precision training in there, which
didn't work with torch because of the
way their numeric are. And it got all
the way up to 13 or 14 million steps per
second training, which is just
completely unheard of, right? I don't
think most people in RL would even
consider that possible. And I've tried
this on several different libraries and
unless you're like massively cheating
with the parameters and doing something
like some completely impractical
configuration, you can't get close to
these speeds.
But lo and behold, if you write it
yourself, you can.
Um,
and then we looked at the code a couple
weeks ago and realized, huh, Torch isn't
actually doing all that much anymore.
We've kind of shipped athesis in, right?
Like every little thing that Torch was
doing is now our own code replacing it.
What if we just drop torch? So that's
what I've been doing for the last couple
of weeks. And it turns out it's actually
very easy. And we only have a few
hundred lines more code without Torch
now than we previously did with Torch.
So it wasn't even really saving us like
a whole bunch of code at all. And it was
losing all of that performance. And
actually even worse, I think that having
stuff slow obscures the way that you
think about research because you're not
actually thinking about architectures
designed jointly with the hardware that
you can run them on. You're not thinking
about like performance per flop. You're
thinking about performance for the
specific really bad implementation of
this architecture that you have. Um and
in fact it can actually skew you to
thinking about like oh you need a huge
number of environments because it's
inefficient on a smaller number of
environments because the implementation
is bad and in general it really like
limits the set of efficient solutions
that you have because of all the places
where your code is inefficient. So
really just thinking about this whole
stack all the way up and down. The
result of this is now we have a clear
path forward for research. Uh we have
this working out of the box on a ton of
problems. It's easier than ever for
people to get involved in it. You don't
need to learn a huge amount of things.
You just need to learn a very small
low-level toolkit. Um, you can run at
home on a single GPU, even a very
low-end one. If you don't have one, you
can rent one online for 5 cents an hour
that will train faster than pretty much
anything else out there.
And the future of ARL is now very, very
bright. And what I'm going to be doing
in the next few months is cleaning this
all up for a release late Super Fast
thing. Let me show one quick demo before
I take questions. and we will discuss
this from there
just to show you that uh this is in fact
real
here's training of breakout locally.
This is on my low-end machine that is
also streaming the uh the video and
stuff. This is 6 seconds on a 5070. It's
like four or 5 seconds on a 5090.
It's perfectly reproducible, fully
deterministic training as well
and you solve the whole game and it's
not just breakout, right? Of course,
we've tested on the other environments
and it works just as well there as well.
And that is what I have for you. So,
I'll be happy to take questions from
here.
>> Thank you, Joseph. That was great. Does
anyone have any any questions?
>> Yeah.
>> So I mean Joseph, you talked a lot about
sort of the simpler vital which are
useful for research and then also about
neural MMO which introduces some of
these more complex behaviors that are
super interesting to study. Where do you
see like the the frontier of the the
next environment? So where is that
going?
>> I think I caught the second uh part of
the question. This was about increasing
uh increasing complexity in environment
design and the types of problems we can
solve next. Does I hear that correctly?
>> Yeah, pretty much.
>> Yeah. So, I mean I can show you if you
just pull up puffer
We have a ton of them here. And neural
MMO is pretty much the hardest thing we
have at the moment. Uh this still takes
640 billion steps to solve or not to
solve to get a third of the way solved.
It's not a solved environment. So my
hope is that within the next version or
so we will have this solved faster as a
combination of pure speed and some
algorithmic advancements that we have
planned.
Uh once we have this solved, my
expectation is we'll pretty much be able
to solve medium complexity tasks either
out of the box or with one
hyperparameter sweep. So essentially, if
the simulation is set up reasonably, it
will just solve. And then we start
looking at harder tasks. Now, for harder
tasks, there are a couple different
things we can do. First of all, we're
not just doing games. We have stuff on
drones, courtesy of uh Sam and Finn
here. Uh we have a big collab with NYU
on autonomous driving that's actually
used by multiple companies. Uh and we do
work professionally for clients as well
in a variety of different areas. But
actually it turns out that the games end
up being a really really good proxy.
Like if you do well on the games, you
just do well overall. And we still have
a lot of them that we can do better on.
I think longer term we're just going to
end up needing to implement some harder
games. Like a fullscale MMO would be
pretty awesome. We actually have some
plans around how we might be able to do
that. Um, there are some other tasks as
well that are visually a lot simpler but
are actually very very good for research
like solving big majes. Mazes 2048
Soabon these are all like surprisingly
really really good indicators for what
seems like a simple problem but actually
works on harder problems and uh
ultimately we are going to want to get
this into important application areas. I
I am personally very interested in
molecular simulation, molecular level
simulation for both uh biological
applications as well as material
sciences. The difficulty with that in my
mind is simply the lack of
interpretability. So I want to have RL
working really well on games mostly
first and do the client stuff on the
side before we really focus on going
into a big application area because of
the interpretability. So when something
doesn't work, I want to be 100% sure
that it's because of the simulation or
the way the problem is set up, not
because of the RL. And that was like
nuts two years ago. We were so far away
from that, but now it's like within a
year, I think. Um, and that's pretty
awesome. I also think this is going to
become the biggest hobby area of AI
because you can do it at home and you
can learn some game programming, you can
learn some low-level dev, you can
advance science and get into AI. It's a
really, really great way to learn all
these things.
Any more questions?
Yeah.
So kind of for for more like real world
situations rather than video games.
Okay. So the the question is um when
we're looking at kind of real world
problems rather than um video games is
the is the main bottleneck mainly in the
compute or within how the environment or
simulation is written?
>> It's actually in the interpretability
for the most part because as you're
building the sim if stuff isn't working
like you need to know why and as the RL
gets better it's more and more because
you wrote the sim wrong. uh it gets
easier the more confident you are is
because you wrote the sim wrong. You do
end up having to spend more time writing
visualization tools. But that's fine.
But on the actual problem complexity
level, we have not found client
applications to be harder to solve than
video games when correctly written. Like
it's shocking how well these things just
Yeah. If it works better 2048, it works
better driving. It works better at, you
know, finance applications, commerce,
whatever.
>> What's what's the best way to get
involved with with the puffer liib going
forward?
>> Ah, thank you very much. First of all,
everybody be the puffer star on GitHub.
Helps me out a lot. And uh if you want
to get involved with development,
discord.gg/puffer.
We run all the dev through there.
Everything here is open source. Um,
we've had literally brand new
programmers get involved with this. It
is better if you've taken one systems
course. That's all you need. It's very
simple C for the most part. Uh, to be
able to like write environments and get
started. And then typically what we do
is I have this nice guide I walk people
through. Um, you start writing very
simple M. You write a couple more
complex M. From there you get a feel for
how RL works. You fill in gaps with
different papers that like a pretty
small list of short papers to read and
then you can start working on science
and research side pro. uh projects as
well. That's kind of the pipeline that
people go through.
>> Well, we've probably got time for a
couple more if
>> uh the question is about if if you see
any kind of applications of
reinforcement learning to cyber security
or cyber offense.
I know that there are people that do
that and they do it without language
models as well. I don't know the details
of the problem setup cuz you essentially
need a big fancy sim that's fast and
that you can simulate the actions an
actor would take. Um, if you're going
over the space of arbitrary shell
scripts, that's pretty hard to do with
tabular rasa RL. Um I think people have
come up with ways to formulate that that
are a little bit more sensible but I
don't have domain expertise in that
area.
>> Yep.
>> Um the past like supervised learning is
currently the most popular method of
training different
um mainly because the learning was
obviously very slow but just become so
much faster by the work that you've
done. Do you believe there's a chance
that reinforcement learning in future of
course once all the capabilities like
you looked into um do you think there's
a chance of important learning I guess
takes over as the most popular way of
trading AI?
>> No, I think it has its place. I let me
repeat the the question. So the question
was like okay supervised learning was
the fastest thing. Uh everybody does
supervised learning. Maybe there was
some RL, but does RL being so much
faster mean that RL is now going to be
the dominant way of training things? I
mean, we've seen people doing RL as
post- training even on language models.
That's actually a very very weak form of
RL. So, it's kind of funny to me that
even that is useful. Um, but I think
you're just going to see it for
different applications. I think that
it's generally false that that people
are saying like, oh yeah, language
models just solve everything. Unless
they literally write the code for the
sim and write the RL code. I don't see
how that's possible because things are
computationally irreducible. You have to
sometimes either do the thing or run a
good sim in order to get the outcome. I
think that what it's more likely to see
is you're going to see a lot more
reinforcement learning on scattered
applications throughout industry where
anywhere that things are currently using
simulation that can be made fast.
simulation is just going to become a
dramatically more powerful tool for
solving problems because instead of
pressing a button and like okay I set up
the initial conditions I think this is
reasonable let's see what the outcome is
now you can just set up a sim specify
the outcome you want and see if the
thing can get there and see the pattern
so that makes sim way more powerful and
that's what I'm excited about especially
how that's going to uh how that is going
to impact different areas of scientific
research
Cool. Any other questions from anyone?
>> Yeah.
I I think recently I think Google
produced some like new like generative
model building and such. So like I guess
my question is related to what I guess
your general thoughts about like
generative AI applied to like building
simulations or world models or like
video games of that nature and if
there's a place for that to help improve
reinforcement learning.
>> So using generative AI to build Sims is
it specifically do you mean like writing
the code for Sims or just generating the
outputs directly?
>> I so I guess I'm not sure. I guess I saw
like in the video that Google Deep
released it was like building the entire
like world uh environment like it's like
a playable environment that uh like
users can interact with. So I guess it
could just be the output itself.
>> Yeah. So the output itself I'm very
bearish on that line of work because
those things are more than 10,000 times
slower than what I'm doing. um it's just
massively inefficient and there's no
reason to expect the training data that
they have to transfer to other
applications we care about.
Reinforcement learning is really good at
fiddly unintuitive optimization
problems. So like you know does training
on a bunch of walking around data or
video game data help your generative
model solve molecular simulation?
Probably not. But reinforcement learning
will probably do it. So I I don't like
this approach in general. Like whether
you can have language models writing
code for Sims. I mean they can kind of
help. You can see me fighting with some
of these on stream all the time. I
actually don't really use LLMs very much
in my simulation code at all. I mostly
use it for dealing with big bloated
other pieces of code. The simulation
code is actually very chill to write
from scratch and uh mostly the models
just make a mess of it so far. Um, I
think if anything though, like if you're
going to bet on the bigger models being
useful in this line of work, you're
betting on them being useful for
developing sims and improving the
research in general, not for zeroing the
outputs of the sim. Um, because that to
me at like I don't see how you get
training data for the stuff that you'd
actually care about with RL. Now, it's
like I'm not saying RL is going to be
useful everywhere and that that's useful
nowhere, but for the specific approach
like problems where RL is good, I just
don't see a path where those methods
would overtake what we're doing with RL.
>> No, I think that's all we've got.
Joseph, thank you very much.
>> Thank you.
Thanks everyone. Bye.
>> Thank you very much. That was great. I
really enjoyed it.
>> Okay, folks on YouTube and Twitch, I
just saw in the chat I've been a total
goober and I forgot to get you uh the
slides. So, here's what we're going to
do. I am going to get this fod
downloaded after uh after the stream and
uh Whoever wants to like edit these two
together, I'll pay I'll like PayPal them
a hundred bucks or whatever. How's that?
So, we can actually get this thing like
bod reported correctly. My bad on that.
Um,
let me grab my chair back and stuff.
Actually, here's what we're going to do
everyone. I'm going to be developing
stuff all pretty much all day after
this. Uh, it's only noon, so I've got
another five, six hours to work on
neural not neural well on Puffer Lib 4.
Uh we're going to be trying to get the
models to be clean. We're going to be
trying to fix up the optimizer today,
maybe even doing some of the kernel dev.
So you'll get to see some of the
low-level stuff. It is still a bunch of
refactor and cleanup. But it would be
good to have some user input on like
does this look readable? Does that look
like something you could use? Um y'all
give me like five minutes. I'm going to
shut the stream up. I'll turn it back on
with the new title. I got to move my
chair back. I got to move my green
screen. And then we'll be good. Yeah,
I can do it. Sure thing, Weston. If you
want to do it, by all means, that'd be
great. Yeah, reserved for you. I'll give
you a few days to uh to or even longer
to do that. Sure. Uh yeah, I'll be back
in a few Oh, for folks who are new
around here, please do start Puffer on
GitHub if you're not going to watch the
the dev stream later. It really really
does help me out. It's free. It's on
puffer.ai.
And I will be uh yeah, I'll